bonjour ici steve kaufmann je suis le
fondateur de link je parle
onze longues et mes idées sur
l'apprentissage des langues et dit je
vais vous expliquer un peu comment moi
gérons les langues et comment tirer
avantage de notre site pour
l'apprentissage des langues qui elik
d'abord le point le plus important c'est
que pour à pouvoir apprendre les langues
il faut aimer la langue il faut faire
des choses qui sont agréables
il faut avoir du plaisir dans
l'apprentissage et pour moi ça vous dit
ça veut dire écouter et lire des choses
qui sont intéressantes et des choses qui
ne sont pas trop difficiles pour moi il
n'est pas nécessaire de faire des
exercices de grammaire
il n'est même pas nécessaire de
comprendre les explications de grammaire
je ne passe pas beaucoup de temps à
étudier mon vocabulaire
parce que moi ce que j'aime faire c'est
d'écouter et de lire des choses que je
trouve intéressant et agréable
est ce que nous avons fait à linx que
nous avons facilité l'apprentissage
à partir donc de contenus intéressants
donc notre système va assurer que
d'abord vous pouvez choisir ce qui vous
intéresse et vous allez pouvoir choisir
du contenu un niveau qui correspond à
peu près à votre niveau
donc qui n'est pas trop difficile il
n'est pas nécessaire de parler tout le
temps pour apprendre mais vous avez la
possibilité avec de parler avec des
natifs des gens qui parlent la langue
que vous êtes en train d'apprendre
vous pouvez écrire et et elle est membre
de notre communauté vont corriger des
choses que j'avais écrit écrite mais
l'important le plus important c'est de
prendre du plaisir dans l'apprentissage
donc prenez le temps de bien comprendre
notre site
il y a beaucoup de fonctions qui vont
vous aider à apprendre mais surtout
amusez vous et comme cela vous allez
avoir du succès merci beaucoup au revoir